welcome to future talk the show that
examines the global impact of technology
both for good and for bad
our society is heavily dependent on
technology but maintaining that
technology requires people who are very
well educated especially in math and
science but our methods of teaching math
have hardly changed in the past several
centuries but that may be about to
change
i have three guests to discuss some of
the new approaches to teaching
mathematics peter freese is president
and ceo of the tech museum of innovation
which is the underwriter for this
program and he's also an experienced
clock maker
keith devlin is a mathematician and
executive director of stanford
university's h-star institute which
studies the relationship between people
and technology he won the 2007 carl
sagan award for science outreach
activities and is known to npr listeners
as the math guy on weekend edition he's
written 28 books and is now working on a
project to use video game technology to
help middle school students learn
mathematics
salman khan is the founder of the khan
academy
which is a one-man internet venture that
aims to provide free world-class
education to anyone anywhere in the
world
his 1400 plus videos on youtube have
garnered over 16 million views
and have received glowing testimonials
from all over the world
khan academy is now the most popular
open education k-12 education resource
on the internet
and it's recently been profiled on cnn
npr and the pbs newshour
salman received the 2009 microsoft
education award at the tech museum in
san jose for using technology to benefit
humanity i'd like to welcome all of you
to the program tonight and peter let me
start with you what is the tech museum
doing to advance new math education
first of all if you go to a museum
especially to a science museum like the
tech museum is
then there is mass everywhere in every
object you you have mass somehow
what is the difference to the normal
school industry
when you come to a museum you have to
explore the space for yourself you have
to be very active
and it's up to you what you learn
but
parallel to this
the tech museum offers some very
interesting programs one especially is
where we bring teachers
kids and parents together in one
classroom because as we always know kids
go home and say we i have a problem to
understand and you have to have
education from your parents
so
sometimes parents don't even have have
learned themselves what is now going on
at school and therefore building this
triangle between teacher kids and
parents is a very very helpful thing and
that happens at the tech museum so is
this sort of an experimental prototype
where you're experimenting with
different ways of learning the role of
the parent the role of the teacher the
role of the student himself exactly the
tech museum would not be in silicon
valley if we would not do these kind of
experiments all the time so we're
looking for new ways of how to bring
these difficult subjects closer to the
people
that people really
can make use of what they've learned in
the museum and becoming a
a global citizen a well-informed citizen
about science that you know problems
like we have them right now down in
florida cannot happen or
going to be treated in a much different
way so does this approach does it get
outside the museum so where for example
school districts are watching your
experiments and what you're doing
and seeing how they could apply it to
their own teaching
yeah we are working together with
teachers we are working together with
the kids and we let them participate in
building the museum
for instance we have a program right now
where kids are in front of teachers
getting educated on a science
subject for about 20 minutes and then
they have to repeat what they've learned
in front of a camera
and these videos are really really good
they show us what people can learn in 20
minutes and how they explain what
they've learned to the audience and
those videos finally end up in the
museum itself in front of the science
experiment so the video basically with
the kid on the video explains the
science experiment there are no labels
anymore
well i gather that there is a need to
upgrade teaching because it hasn't
really changed much lately and the needs
have changed so keith how long has it
been since there has been a major
upgrade to the way mathematics is taught
well the three images that i've brought
along to show to the audience are from a
book that was written in 1202 it's by
leonardo of pisa it was written in latin
it's called libra bache it means the
book of calculation can we see those
pictures we i think we have those uh
images let's go ahead and show those
pictures okay so this book appears in
1202 it was the first arithmetic book
that ever appeared in western europe
it looks very little different from an
arithmetic book today it's that the
language has changed we don't write our
books in latin anymore they've got a
little bit thinner that was about 600
pages but essentially arithmetic
teaching hasn't changed in the west in
800 years now one might say if uh if a
system is worked for 800 years why does
it need to change well i think many
people in our audience will say that it
hasn't worked very well we've been using
it we've used textbooks because for 800
years that was the only way we could
capture
mathematical knowledge on any kind of
device that we could distribute to a
large number of people it had to be text
but mathematics isn't about facts
mathematics is a way of thinking about
the world problems in the world it's
something you do now how do you what's
the best way to learn something you do
you do it if you want to learn to play
chess you can learn the rules from a
book but you won't learn to play chess
until you play the game if you want to
learn to play tennis the book will tell
you something but you've got to go out
and play tennis you can't always learn
by going out and doing the real thing
for example if you want to learn how to
fly an airplane you learn in a simulator
if you want to learn how to be a brain
surgeon you will be trained in a
simulator the us army uses simulators to
train troops before they go to iraq now
how does this apply to mathematics so
mathematics learning is more like
learning to be a soldier because there's
a danger element that people will get
scared the best way to learn mathematics
is either in a real world environment
where you're using that mathematics and
those are difficult to come across
especially with classes full of students
or you learn it in a simulator and the
modern word for a simulator is a video
game that's why i've spent the last five
years looking at how you can use video
games massively multiplayer online games
to provide environments in which
students can learn mathematics in a real
environment when you talk about teaching
people how to think mathematically what
does that look like how does a person
who thinks mathematically differ from a
person who does not think mathematically
in almost every respect for example we
don't get nervous when numbers are
banded around
we know what the numbers mean we know
that if the prices go up 10 this week
and come down 10 next week they don't go
back to where they were we just have
this sense of what the numbers mean and
what video games are ideal for you can
use them for doing all kinds of
mathematics but what they're ideal for
is getting people to that familiarity
with numbers and quantities that are
really part and parcel of being a
citizen in the 21st century in a country
like the united states so we're getting
away from the traditional rote learning
where you just memorize everything
whether you really understand it or not
mathematics today more than at any time
in history it's important to be able to
think like a mathematician you actually
no longer need to do a lot of the
detailed mathematics we have machines
like this device like that peter's got
next to me that will do mathematics for
us we have computers to do that we have
checkout machines at the supermarket
doing the calculations is not as
important as it was when i was a child
but thinking mathematically that's the
coin of the realm in the 21st century i
think the students of the future will be
very happy to learn that they'll be able
to spend their math class playing video
games i would hope they would because
learning math should be fun and by golly
we can make it fun now you're working on
this project where is this project is
this game ready to roll off the show
absolutely no we we
we started off five years ago thinking
that this might cost 30 40 50 million
dollars my current estimate is this is a
500 million dollar operation at least
i'm now calling this the apollo program
in mathematics education it's the
educational equivalence of putting some
person on the moon we want to put some
person into a mathematical mind and keep
them alive if you want so it's got to be
a big national program this is not
something that even a large video game
company can do this has to be a national
initiative because that's the only way
to do something on this scale now that's
very interesting because you're talking
about a 500 million dollar expenditure
to build this video program now sal
uh you've created khan economy which
essentially provides free education
which costs next to nothing to produce
and you've had 16 million viewers
already
what is khan academy actually and how
does it really work
yeah so most people
know it as this library of 1400 videos
on youtube and as you mentioned it's got
16 million views it's now the most
viewed
open education library more than
especially on youtube more than mit and
stanford and and all of the videos have
been made by me i'm the faculty of the
khan academy and uh the goal is to
i'm going to keep making videos but
we're supplementing that with a software
piece and eventually build a community
around the site so that students can
start teaching each other and the goal
is really to
to be a free virtual school for the
world a place where anyone can go to the
site and learn at their own pace get
feedback get data on what they're doing
and
start at any point and get to any point
if you go to the site right now you'll
see there's a video literally on one
plus one equals two that's the very
first arithmetic video and the videos
you know 1400 videos is a lot of
material it goes all the way up to uh
you know the last calculus video i did
was a surface integral and you can go
into differential equations and and
physics and there's even stuff on the
financial crisis and all of that so the
goal is to start at a basic level and go
as far as you need to go now before we
discuss khan academy further we're
actually going to view some excerpts
from some of your videos so what are we
going to see in these excerpts yeah the
one thing that i i think stands out to a
lot of people is that the form factor
for the khan academy is
fairly different than what you would
expect
as online video you're not going to see
the instructor you're not going to see
someone at a whiteboard kind of teaching
away from you
all you see is a black background some
writing in different colors that look
nice and a voice and and i like to end
the voices this voice and i like to
think that it's kind of it's more of an
experience of me sitting next to you and
and we're doing a tutoring session or me
being in your head yeah
and and uh
and more of an intimate kind of
one-on-one tutoring informal type of
framework i think
okay so we're going to go ahead and roll
that video let's take a look at sal's
video and then we'll come back and
discuss it further let's roll that tape
so notice we interpreted the statement
in two different ways this was just
straight left to right doing the
addition then the multiplication this
way we did the multiplication first then
the addition we got two different
answers and that's just not cool in
mathematics if so this was part of
some effort to send something to the
moon because two people interpreted a
different way or not one computer
interpreted one way another computer
interpreted another way that the
satellite might go to mars so this is
just completely unacceptable and that's
why we have to have an agreed upon order
of operations an agreed upon way to
interpret this statement
so the agreed upon order of operations
is to do parentheses first let me write
it over here
parentheses
paren
the seas first then do exponents if you
don't know what exponents are don't
worry about it right now
exponents and in this video we're not
going to have any exponents in our
examples
so you don't really have to worry about
them for this video then you do
multiplication i'll just write
mult short for multiplication then you
do multiplication and division next they
kind of have the same level of priority
and then finally you do addition and
subtraction
finally you do addition
and subtractions
a neuron could be you know a reasonably
normal sized cell although there is a
huge range but the axons can be quite
long they could be short sometimes in
the brain you might have very small
axons but you might have axons that go
down the spinal column or that go along
one of your limbs or you know if you're
talking about a dinosaur along with a
dinosaur's limb so the axon can actually
stretch several feet not all neurons
axons are several feet but they could be
and this is really where a lot of the
the distance of the signal gets traveled
so let me draw the axon
so the axon will look something like
this
and at the end
it ends at the axon terminal
where it can connect to other
dendrites or maybe to other types of
tissue or muscle if the point of this
neuron is to tell a muscle to do
something
so let's say i go to the local grocery
store
let me draw that in orange so let's say
i go to some
grocery store over here i'll say g for
grocery and i buy a hundred dollars
worth of groceries and i want to pay
with my newly issued credit card let me
write this down this is the issuing
issuer this is the issuing bank i go to
the grocery store i say hey i'd like to
pay a credit card the grocery store if
they accept credit cards they need to
have some relationship with another bank
someplace on this visa network in order
for them to accept a visa card so let's
say that they have a relationship with
bank b over here this would be
the merchant bank or we could say the
retailer's bank or it's often in credit
card lingo called the acquiring bank or
the acquirer and you might wonder why is
it called the acquirer it's called the
acquire because this is the player that
goes out and goes to each of the
merchants and says hey right now you
only accept cash or you only expect
except american express wouldn't it be
great if you also accepted visa or
mastercard that way you'll have a more
appeal to more customers and you know
every time it'll be more convenient for
your customers and every time a
transaction happens we'll just take a
little bit of a cut of that transaction
and so they go out and acquire
different retailers
i guess that was some sample videos from
khan academy and i like your style of
delivery because i don't think you're
going to lose anyone it's kind of folksy
you're not
rushing through it but it looks like the
videos are very simple to produce that
looks like they cost next to nothing to
create
um
is there anything preventing other
people from also jumping into this field
and creating their own similar videos
no and i hope they do it literally to
produce these videos i think some of the
people at home could start doing it
tonight you just need a little pen towel
but you can get it the local electronic
store for under 100
i use screen capture you can get
shareware versions and i'm just using an
art program i started doing microsoft
paint i've now used other
slightly more fancy shareware pieces of
programming uh but it's it's it's very
simple very easy i started doing it just
because
i was remotely tutoring my cousins in
new orleans and when i was doing that we
just had a shared whiteboard and we
didn't see each other and it seemed to
work so i figured hey why not do the
same thing and then i wouldn't have to
get a camera crew and all of that on uh
yeah now how are the videos used is this
something that a person just watches at
home alone or
can this be brought into a classroom
situation
when i started i envisioned it being
some type of a supplemental
material for for students when they're
home if they need to remediate fill in
gaps in their knowledge they can just
dive in and get a 10 minute nugget that
fills in a basic building block and they
can pause and repeat it as much as they
want but i've gotten a lot of feedback
it's starting to be used in the
classroom and really it's it's an
organic process and it it makes a lot of
sense if you if you think about it right
now i've gotten an email from a teacher
in london that said we've flipped the
model we are now
instead of doing lecture in the
classroom and homework at home i now
assign khan academy videos at home where
the students can watch it at their own
pace at their own time pause and repeat
fill in their their their gaps in their
knowledge and then when you come to the
classroom then you do your homework and
then you can you get the benefit of the
teacher being around the teacher can
observe what what students are doing and
the students can help each other so
you're actually taking advantage of the
the the the social aspects of a
classroom to actually teach each other
so
it can be used either it could be used
for a homeschooler i've gotten
letters from parents who one they use it
for their their their their kids but
they also use it to stay ahead of their
kids so that they can
they can teach them you know what one
step ahead so it's really uh i'm
learning of new applications for it
every day
so like how do the teachers know that
the kids mastered the material would
they still have the same traditional
test or could you have a thing where
a child finishes one video
they somehow demonstrate that they have
absorbed what it taught and then they go
on to the next video and so people kind
of work at their own pace
yeah and and when i started the khan
academy it's most known for the videos
but there's an entire software piece
that i started really building for my
cousins and now several tens of
thousands of people are using the
software and the idea is you start
everyone at one plus one there's these
little modules people can log in right
now and start working on it starts at
one plus one equals two and the paradigm
isn't get eighty percent right and
you're a c student or ninety percent
right you're a b or ninety five percent
you're an a student the paradigm is get
ten in a row because even if you're an a
student and you got 95 right what was
that 5
and matt you know i think we can all
appreciate in mathematics if you have
even a 5 gap when you build on top of
that that you know you don't know what
something is to the 0th power then when
you see it in calculus you're like gee i
don't know i was an a student but i
still didn't know that one special case
so the paradigm is get 10 in a row and
as you get 10 in a row you get and while
you're doing the module is tracking
everything
every interaction with with the actual
software so if you think about it you're
getting instruction from the video
you're getting practice and feedback
directly from the software in real time
and then everything is being tracked so
it's actual real-time assessment that's
actionable the teachers can actually get
data on what to do about what students
and everyone's working at their own pace
because the tradition is that everybody
goes in lockstep which is bad in two
respects one respect uh the slow kids
get left behind the other respect is
that the fast kids are held back and and
the real irony is sometimes there's a
flipping of you know i think that we've
had the experience where you're like oh
this is easy and you're kind of bored
and all of a sudden wait wait i missed
that and you're now you've now fallen
behind and so what and i've seen it in
the data of students using the software
is that
sometimes a student will when they're
working at their own pace a student that
you might say is slow initially because
they're spending more time on one
concept once they get that out of the
they race forward so it's actually very
hard to predict who are the slow or the
fast students and so it's and you know
just going back to the traditional model
it's
on some level you know we've gotten so
used to it because it's a thousand years
old but we don't question this idea of
passively getting lectures then you go
home and you do things in a vacuum and
you keep doing that process for several
days and then you get a snapshot
assessment and when you get the
assessment it tells you you knew 80 of
that concept
and in the normal world when you're
learning something if i if i only know
to ride a bike 80 of the way i'm going
to keep sitting on that bike until i can
always you know before before i try out
a unicycle yeah and a lot of people seem
to have a real math phobia i've known
people who just don't believe they can
understand anything in math and it might
be because
they missed one like it's a chain of
knowledge and if one link in the chain
is broken then you lose the rest of the
chain but here
you don't advance to the next link until
you're sure that you've mastered this
link right you know there's a couple of
i'm convinced that a lot of the
frustration that goes on in algebra
class isn't uh because the student is
slow or because the teacher is bad it's
just that the student has a weakness in
borrowing numbers or negative numbers
and there's no way in that algebra class
to address that negative number the
student might not even know that they
have that basic weakness in negative
numbers and they just keep talking past
each other so
i i think you're exactly right that's
the problem is that no matter how good
you do the traditional model how good
the actors are in it if you have this
basic core weakness there's no way to
address it in the traditional model let
me throw out a question that you know
any of you can feel free to answer is
learning itself and art
the usual model is that the child is a
passive vessel in which you pour the
knowledge
uh is learning something that you have
to know how to do like you have to learn
how to learn before you can even start
you know the museum
the the game
program and in your methodology really
teaches us
when we learn it that
there's a different way of learning
where you you are the master of the
speed how fast you learn
you go forwards and backwards it's your
choice so people who come to museums
they give random a chance they run
around they discover their talents so
learning is not working in the future i
think with a teacher outside and a lot
of kids sitting there and just watching
at this teacher i think we want to be
part of this learning process and we
want to really organize it ourselves and
i think in all of our three cases that's
happening nowadays
i mean that's the power of a video game
in the video game the player is the star
of that universe it revolves around you
they design that way and remember human
beings as a safe species we survived
because we learned to learn we are the
learning species we are programmed from
birth to learn in an environment where
it's important to learn and you get
immediately and you get immediate
feedback
just as with cells in video game
learning it reverses everything what
does the teacher say go home tonight
your homework is to acquire the sword of
doom we build that game so acquiring the
sword of doom requires solving some math
problems the child probably won't solve
the problems that night so they go back
in the teacher says go and look at khan
academy and you'll find on video 35
exactly what you need to go back in
tomorrow night and capture the sword of
doom the child now is motivated in a
right environment
and they've got all the resources
available teacher textbooks videos
brings it all together i think a lot of
people who have made the greatest
contributions in computer science didn't
make it because of what they learned
sitting in classrooms it's what they did
at home playing and putting things
together they dropped out many of them
dropped out of school yeah and you know
to your point about this learning to
learn and is there i i you know i have a
15 month old
son
and he is a natural learner just like
what these guys are talking about that
he that's all he wants to do in fact if
you take him away from exploring and
playing with something and seeing
understanding that that's what upsets
him and i think the problem isn't that
we need to teach people how to learn i
think a lot of our current
institutions actually go in the opposite
direction of our natural learning
instincts they force they even though
you want to be active and engaged and
and and explore things they're treating
you like a a vessel that needs
information to be poured in and in here
go ahead you know in 1980s that's now 30
years ago i learned latin at a school
and i was not really good at latin so i
bought one of the first laptops i put
all the vocabulary of this book into
this little computer and the computer
was asking me the word i typed it in and
when i typed it correctly in it he
erased it
if i made an error he recorded it and
then he asked me the wrong ones again
yeah and you know i i basically learned
how to program basic at those days you
know my latin didn't really improve but
so instant feedback is really important
you don't pour knowledge into the vessel
all year and at the end of the year you
give a one-time test to see what they
learn and then move on if they
didn't now there are a lot of good
methods to improve education but you
know for example here in the state of
california education is a huge
bureaucracy and bureaucracies are highly
resistant to change is there any way
that
some of the ideas we're talking about
could actually find its way into this
big massive inertial system
well
one thing i'm seeing just from letters
from khan academy users and i'm getting
a couple hundred every day now is that
some students are using khan academy as
their primary instruction and they're
just showing up at their university or
their high school just to kind of show
what they've learned and so i i think
it's hard to change the system you know
it's a big beast and you gotta kind of
massage it slowly but i think over time
when people find these alternate sources
for learning their information and
professors start to say wait gee people
are just showing up that i'm just a test
administrator i'm not actually they're
learning someplace else hopefully the
system itself will say gee maybe we need
to
reflect you know i don't understand why
there are 300 person lecture rooms
anymore i mean if you think about it
on-demand video is better in every
single way a 300-person lecture room is
a complete broadcast completely passive
on-demand video you can pause repeat
watch your own time but but the inertia
the bureaucracy is continuing to do i
mean even a 20 person classroom you have
to question but 300 percent i can't you
know i've challenged everyone no one can
think of why this exists but at every
university you pay 30 000 a year they
stick in these rooms and you get a
broadcast but i think we're in the
middle of that really social change
already and yeah it's happening you know
you prove it
around the edges but it can happen on
the edges because one guy in a converted
closet can reach 16 million people yeah
i mean the technology allows small
groups of people to make big changes
well the internet is really the backbone
of the change because that is what
enables the instant communication from
anywhere to anyone at almost no cost
and we're always looking for new ways to
apply this and we're probably at the
very beginning of figuring out you know
how to really apply it
yeah so that what's your economic model
for this so you give the product away
for nothing
that's a mysterious
it's uh uh you know i i used to work in
the hedge fund world i was an analyst
and and i was doing all of this part
time starting for my cousins really
started to take off and in september i
just felt it's all for a not-for-profit
basis khan academy is a 501c3
organization and we could talk about why
i decided to do that there was some
temptation to go on people can donate
without
yeah
yeah they could donate but i i'm limited
to it
but uh uh it was initially uh
essentially self-funded and uh there's
some donations coming from the viewers
just spontaneous donations and there's a
little bit of advertising that's going
to khan academy.org i wasn't taking a
salary until
unfortunately i'm going to have to cut
you off because i just got the signal
that we're just about totally out of
time okay so we're going to have to wrap
the show i'd like to thank my three very
distinguished guests
peter friese keith devlin salman khan
thanks to all of you for being here and
advancing public knowledge on how to
improve math training so we can
continue to maintain this huge
technological society we've created
thank you for watching be sure to tune
in next time i'm marty wasserman see you
next time
you